very happy to be joined by the dudes
from capybara games nathan bella and
chris petrosky wonder if i get right
that was really a yeah nailed it the
hardest part of this job is seeing
people's names on Twitter for like four
years and then [ __ ] up their surnames
realizing you never actually sent it to
yourself in your never know nathan is
alive yeah he be lying so Nathan apart
from being everyone's favorite Canadian
video game awards show host you also are
a frequent visitor to our what's going
on Mary commanders you want this what
for me can I have both of them alright
double-double Mike I'm going to double
down apart from that you also create
video games on come on our show like
every other week to talk about them yeah
the last time I saw you you were handing
me a beer after all this is the best
fear that I've ever had so yeah word
maybe even feel extra bad phenomena beer
you should have had years for us
actually that's okay you're here to show
up below which is playable on the show
floor yeah I was complain but we
announced it on stage at the microsoft
e3 press conference last year and then
kind of went dark while we were making
it and now PAX East is the perfect place
for us to kind of open it up and let's
invite everyone play it if actually we
realized that we showed super time force
for the very first time at PAX East now
we're showing below for the very first
time in taxis so basically where'd you
hear we're just going to keep making
games just to reveal at PAX East that's
right we got a staple like the behemoth
booth yeah and there since the dawn of
time forever it's actually the pax
monolith so yeah we're here to show
we're here to show below below is
cappy's roguelike inspired adventure
game it's it's all about you as a tiny
character in a rather large world and
chris is gonna dive right in and give
her some give her some going you can you
can start playing me you can start
playing the video game Oh am i playing
now you're playing people see me playing
we're also going to take my skank there
you go shut up raise your hand and one
of our lives their audio it'll be four
they'll be to begin not use here Danny
alright
I can scream if you want okay your voice
will last 12 minutes you saying I should
turn on my microphone this is how we
roll man I love it hello hello below go
for it there we go sorry so yeah below
is is our new game coming to steam and
xbox one we just announced the steam
part of that recently so very excited to
get it to our PC fans and and below is a
game where you arrive in an island we
don't show you any text we don't tell
you why you're there there's no real
tutorials we just let you go and the
goal of the game is to explore its to
survive and through those two you end up
discovering why you're there what the
island is why you're delving through the
depths of the island and and you get to
do a heck of a lot of really badass
combat and it's brutal you're going to
die a hell of a lot it seems to be a
theme of games lately bit you're going
to die a lot but you're definitely going
to die and then the next version of you
comes and it's sequential you're not
just responding and restarting the game
over and over again you're actually
another wanderer showing up at the
island after the last one okay and the
work that you do the things that you
achieve the stuff that you find in one
playthrough carries over to the next one
cool so if you pick up an item and go a
couple levels deeper and then die well
that item is actually on your corpse
it's not going to just magically appear
back where it was so you actually have
to like go through and find your corpses
and in you know through each life
progress further through the depths so
this is kind of I guess maybe a
spiritual successor to sorcery obviously
Chris working on that and get both we
doing the music
the art style is kind of similar enough
is this a very different gameplay
experience to what superb wrote a short
story yeah definitely I mean
stylistically I think it's there's
similarities we work definitely focusing
on a very specific kind of mood and a
specific sort pace but then once you get
into sort of the nitty-gritty of the of
the game it's a completely different
game I mean it's it's really very much
about you know learning how to become
good at the combat learning how to
understand like what's going on in the
environment so in terms of like just
pure pure gameplay it has a much denser
richer sort of experience than sorcery I
guess in the more traditional gaming
sort of sense you guys set the right
from the start here I've got to play
this on the show floor down at the
Double Fine booth and it starts off with
that really long climb up the wall and
then you know you're then you're
descending here and what struck me is
the size of the character relative to
the rest of the screen I was trying to
figure out the last game that I played
where there's such a discrepancy between
you know that you guys were using all of
this space and being so small what would
be that how is that it was sort of the
inspiration for that aesthetic and you
guys trying to make me feel like here
cuz i feel kind of lonely oh we're
trying to make you feel like a
completely fragile and insignificant me
being that's very sweet of you yeah and
it's you're welcome for from the very
beginning of the very first time the
chris even pitched us the concept at the
studio the idea was to create this like
sense of scale that you're small you're
weak you're one mistake away from dying
it basically every turn and in order to
do that we really wanted to play that up
with most of the dungeons in the game
which are entirely procedurally
generated our single screens so you have
a very clear sense of scale it's very
clear that you're small and the world is
much larger but you also know where you
can explore and because it's inspired by
roguelikes there are certain things like
the fact that is procedurally generated
and
death is permanent the way that health
works into the game is that you take
damage and even the smallest amount of
damage will start you bleeding and if
you don't deal with the fact that you're
bleeding like a normal human you will
eventually bleed to death so a little
little insignificant enemy not dealt
with correctly can't kill you if you
don't know what you're doing and then
all I like making hard games we do we
this game is meant to be challenging and
it's we love the wheel of the audience
of hard games when we love hard games
ourselves whether it's super time force
or below both of those games are meant
to be challenging games that are going
that you learned through do it you learn
through playing you learn through
experiencing the world and then learning
about it and coming back the next time
and may be dying on a spike trap and
just die you did die a lot it's amazing
ice we've done how many times have you
done this demo like a thousand times I
played that one up for the crab yeah
that one knew what he was ham and asad
coming from miles away but you as you go
through you will learn like ok these
things are dangerous and a lot of cases
you're learning by poking around just
trying to like search your way through
it and you know maybe that's going to
kill you but the next time you come in
the next wonder that arrives they know
better how difficult is it to demo a
game like this where not only is it like
the mood is so like intimate but then
also the lack of information that you
give in to the players one of these
games where you kind of just have to
learn like feel almost have difficulty
doing how you can play on schedule right
I that environment we've been really
really choked on the fact that people
die again right we go for a record
that's that's our game right there in a
nutshell you've been experienced players
are going to get knocked on their butts
thank you guys I'm just nervous I'm
nervous I've never played it from the
crab hard games government planes been
playing on rock shows
if you've got any questions in fact I
put your hand up oh my god yeah do it
over here you got a mic over there a guy
so let's get that you too Mike Chris
will die like five times before the
might guess you don't worry about this
than that he's focused now look at him
this that is the than I of the tiger
what is this thing gonna hit him card
yes they're like a concept of bosses
within this like games like rogue legacy
have bosses that are like preconceived
will there be like some sort of
randomness of the bosses if there are
some there's a there's a big component
to the game that that we're not talking
to set but it does sort of encapsulate
the boss sort of concept so kind of
roundabout answer yeah yes with a
question mark at the end and I know ?
sorry and I said no if you're able to
talk about it and like you know if
variety of like shadow of colossus and
dark souls so that's the best thing is
never thank you very much worth more
we're friends now awesome thanks very
much great shirt as well add you have
any other questions over there I can't
see yet dude right there bring the plaid
why am I saying that everyone god I'm
wearing that I really enjoy the music a
lot um what kind of the inspiration for
where that came from well the Jim
Guthrie is the guy making the music so
we work with him previously on sword and
sorcery and so such a great experience
that right after that project was done
we were just like you know we knew
either one we wanted to make below right
after that project and we just basically
wanted to work together again and so the
tone oh look at this one killer hahaha
yeah yeah yeah no I got killed because
or a keel over what haha that one was
not my father still a valium extreme
picture I mean we basically got captured
in gym and locked him in a room until I
again below with us he's for those of us
who grew up in Ontario Jim's actually
kind of an indie rock legend he's his
music was like we were listening to it
when we were in university together
and being able to work with someone who
can do sorcery and then do the
soundtrack for indie game the movie and
then do soundtrack for other
documentaries and also you know have
Chris sitting in his studio jamming on
the game to make sure that the game has
the right vibe in the right tone and
that the music works well with what
we're trying to do kind of the space and
with even like making the player maybe
feel a little more lonely in certain
cases or making them feel like maybe
there's something bigger coming up but
just working with someone who can do
that is just my use magnet were you he's
in then into like to doing soundtracks
for video game stuff people like a lot
of people do myself would have assumed
that's how we like that was what he was
doing have no idea Jim Joyce like doing
a whole bunch of amazing indie rock and
then he met Craig d adams from super
brothers and they started doing a couple
little projects together that they did a
like a video called children of the
clone which was Craig's animations to
like Jim started playing around with the
PlayStation music maker quite early on
so he made all these like little fun
bleep igloo p Jim sounds that they do
the same track for VIP ribbon as I would
you say no but it's you know it's got
that kind of crazy weird gym vibe
through a PlayStation music program and
then that was sort of one of the
inspirations for
for the music style of sorcery that sort
of was like building on this thing a
medium that Jim was started doing in his
basement on his own it's a big a big
part of all of our games and this game
especially is we were trying to make a
game that's you know got all really you
know deep gameplay but we're also trying
to make it aesthetically focused and the
visuals in the audio are central to the
experience they're not just something
that kind of America's you need to have
some graphics it's a lot of the game
play in the game is built around the
visual style and around James Missoula
being able to like build a game around
great art and around great sound makes
it a lot easier for us to craft the
exact type of experience that you have a
craft and hopefully the exact experience
that players or where they want to dive
into and poke around in and explore
since coming to xbox one and pc do you
have any other idea of when met about
two players we can i get in 2014 hope so
i remember not two not answering either
yeah then i hope so too we have we have
learned not to go too far ahead of
ourselves you guys take your time as
well we do we really believe that the
best thing that developers can have is a
chance to like spend time with their
projects and we really kind of use the
loaf of bread reference where it needs
time to prove and then it needs time in
the oven and it needs to be golden brown
before we're going to take it out and we
don't think the worst thing that we can
do is the studio is hand unfinished work
to people who are going to pay money for
our stuff we really wanted we want to be
able to look people in the face and tell
them that we think it's great and not be
lying we want to make sure that the
stuff that we put out is what we want to
put out and sometimes that means the
games take a little longer and hopefully
we can do our best to get this one in
people's hands as soon as possible we're
going to be now that it's out there in
the open we've been super quiet about it
now that zone the open we're going to
try to show as much as we can about the
game and try to you know get as many
people seeing as much as we can soon so
stay tuned folks I'm win a super time
force a super time horse is out very
soon
of May early June is what we're looking
at this it's in testing and
certification right now so we're really
excited that's that's a it's the first
time that we really like been able to
look to sit back and say holy crap we
just made a giant crazy platformer with
time travel so yeah it's here with a lot
of fun it's gonna be a heck of a year
first yeah yeah so that's gettin busy
yeah everybody who's been following
super time for so get a chance to play
it real soon on 360 n on xbox one is
more excellent you're good pitch man I
like it I I know my I know my beads and
I know how to hit those marks well last
question are you a gonna host the IGF
Awards exterior I use doc now are you in
are you the new Andy shots I don't have
to do a project to not pull off a pink
shirt like Andy shell of a pink shirt I
think he can i I've never tried actually
well Alexander Bruce is here maybe he
could do it he rocks his picture pretty
good Alexander can do everything better
than everyone so that's not a fair
comparison I don't think they said i
would love to do it again if they'll
have me i was a lot of fun hand and
awards to my friends and people that I
believed really deserved it and also are
telling some jokes and having some fun
I'm drinking some beers yes indeed then
we got next year Nathan Chris thank you
so much for coming on random applause
please for below
you